today on the Matt Walsh show we hear a
lot about non-essential businesses these
days but I want to talk about why I
think there is no such thing as a
non-essential business I think that's a
category that doesn't actually exist
I'll explain why also five headlines
including a mother arrested on a
playground in front of her kids for
bringing her kids to a playground and
airlines are coming up with it looks
like a pretty horrifying way to
reconfigure their seating arrangements
in response to the coronavirus plus the
daily cancellation and your emails and a
lot more all coming up on the show but
first what I tell you about our friends
over at expressvpn you know it's we
often think about internet privacy and
security when we're at the office but
what about when you're at home I think
there's a false sense of security that
sometimes we have that we're at home and
we think we have that privacy being at
stuck at home these days you probably
don't think much about internet privacy
on your own home network even an
incognito mode though your online
activity can still be traced even if you
clear your browsing history your
internet service provider can still see
every single website you've ever visited
that's why even why when I'm at home I
never go online without using Express
VPN expressvpn make sure that your ISP
can't see what sites you visit instead
your internet connection is is rerouted
through Express VPNs secure servers are
each Express VPN server has an IP
address that shared among thousands of
other users that means everything you do
is is is anonymous and it can't be
traced back to you Express vpm also
encrypts 100% of your data with best
with the best-in-class encryption that
you could possibly find so your
information is always protected this is
just about privacy when when you're
online this is all there's something we
all need and wants privacy so to protect
your online activity today with with the
VPN that I trust to secure my privacy
visit my special link at expressvpn comm
slash walsh and you can get the extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's expressvpn comm slash walsh expr
e SS VPN dot-com slash walsh expressvpn
comm slash walsh to learn more okay so
well first of all this isn't what I
originally wanted to talk about to begin
the show but I did
just mention this this controversy
involving the lieutenant governor of
Texas dan Patrick now if you didn't hear
he's getting a ton of criticism and
blowback for something that he said on
Tucker Carlson a few days ago when he
was discussing the corona virus response
he was advocating you know as he's been
an advocate all along for opening the
economy up he made the point at the
mortality rate especially in Texas is
very low and we're killing the economy
and there's gonna be serious
consequences from that so that's that's
his point and in the in the process of
making that point he said this we're
crushing small business we're crushing
the markets we're crushing this country
and what I said when I was with you that
night there are more important things
than living and that's saving this
country for my children and my
grandchildren and saving this country
for all of us and I don't want to die
nobody wants to die but maybe we got a
we got to take some risk and get back in
the game and get this country back up
and running now there's been a huge
freakout over this because he said there
are more important things than living
and to a lot of people these days
apparently that is a scandalous thought
so so people are very upset about that
of course meanwhile he's exactly right
of course of course he's right yes there
are more important things than living
without even knowing the context if you
just told me he said that and I had no
idea of the context even without the
context I I would I would I would agree
I would say well of course there are
more important things than living I can
rattle off a list of things right away
there that are more important than
living faith integrity dignity love you
know I mean basically anything you would
rather die than forfeit anything you
would hold on to until death like if
somebody put a gun to your head and said
give up this or I'll kill you if there's
anything that even in that scenario you
would say well then kill me that means
that you believe there are more
important things than living now if you
have no such things
if somebody put a gun to your head and
you would give up anything at all that
they ask for and do anything that they
want you to do for the sake of just
continuing to breathe that yes for you
there is nothing more important than
living and that isn't that's an
understandable attitude from a sort of
primal self-preservation standpoint but
it's also cowardly and pathetic okay
so there's nothing wrong with this
statement this is ideally no I mean we
can never know exactly how we would
respond if we had a gun to our heads but
ideally I think most of us should be
able to agree that an ideal scenario
there are going to be things more
important to us than living and it
becomes so so the statement is not wrong
the statement becomes even less wrong
and more right when you look at the
context because what he's saying he's
saying as an older man somebody in a
vulnerable group he would rather risk
death for himself for the sake of
preserving our civilization for his
children and grandchildren and everybody
else's children and grandchildren and
that is also the right attitude in fact
I would say if you're a parent and you
don't have that attitude if you are not
willing to risk death for yourself for
the sake of preserving your child's
future then you're a bad parent you
don't love your kids enough in that case
I'm not saying you have to agree with
him about the shutdown if you love your
kids but you should at least agree with
the basic principle that you're willing
to take on a risk for yourself for the
sake of your kids you in principle you
should agree with that or you're not a
good parent and that's all he's saying
so what's the controversy here what are
people freaking out about well they're
freaking out because they're stupid
because we live in a very stupid time
and even very basic easy-to-understand
points become a reason for people to
panic now so so what he's saying
the preservation of his own life is not
the most important thing it's important
but it's not the most important and in
his mind we are doing something with
these shutdowns
that will cause enormous damage to
future generations and ends and to him
that is not a price worth paying
to preserve his life and yes the life of
many you know of the lives of people in
his peer group his age group what he's
saying is that's not worth the cost of
destroying our civilization for our kids
and grandkids and again that how do you
see that as anything but an admirable
attitude now the only problem with this
line from the lieutenant governor is
that it sounds like he's sort of
conceding that the lockdowns are saving
lives but and what he's saying is that
even if they are it's not necessarily
worth the price and he would still be
right even in that case but it's
actually not true necessarily that the
lockdowns are saving lives they may in
fact be doing more harm than good even
with respect to fighting the virus
itself they may be doing more harm than
good so it's not a choice between saving
lives or not it's a choice between
between a dubious method of saving lives
that will also be certain to crash the
economy and bring with it all sorts of
horrific consequences as well or the
choice between that or keeping the
economy going continuing to live our
lives while taking precautions and and
thus trying to stave off the worst case
scenario with the virus as well as the
worst case scenario with an economic
collapse so those are the two choices
it's not true at all that if you're in
favor of the lockdowns you're
necessarily in favor of the method that
will save more lives because it may in
fact not and in fact I've got some stuff
coming up in the in the headline section
that I think shows that there the
consequences of this shutdown may well
kill not just more people than will die
from the virus but a lot more people
exponentially more people speaking of
exponential growth so will
we'll talk about well and we'll talk
more about that in the in the in the
headlines but I do have something else I
wanted to talk about it at the front
before we do a quick word from Rock Auto
you know if you're having car trouble
right now this is a it's a kind of a bad
time for it I've gone through this
already with both of our cars you might
not be able to go out to get out of the
house
maybe the places around you that sell
the auto parts aren't open whatever the
case may be well the good news is
rockauto.com is there the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate rockauto.com is so much easier
than walking into a store so even if you
could go to a store it still is better
to go to rockauto.com and besides when
you go to the store you know they're
gonna ask you a lot of confusing
questions they probably don't have what
you need they're gonna end up ordering
it online anyway why not just cut out
that whole middleman process and go
there yourself rockauto.com is
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
new carpet whatever you need for
whatever kind of car you have they're
gonna have it there at rockauto.com
always offering the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what they think the market will
bear and these days especially right we
all need to save money as much as
possible so go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you now what other
I wanted to make or idea I wanted to
talk about I I thought about this when I
drove to I had to run some essential
errands over the weekend and had to
specifically go to an essential grocery
store to buy some essential food and on
the way there I noticed and I had
noticed this before but Best Buy was
still open there's still people a ton of
people actually in the parking lot at
Best Buy going to Best Buy I also passed
the Dunkin Donuts still open
I passed a Dairy Queen still open
all of these open so apparently Donuts
ice cream TVs these are all considered
essential services and essential
businesses which which doesn't surprise
me in modern America nor do I
necessarily disagree I mean these donuts
ice cream and TV have certainly been
essential components of my own life I
will I will certainly admit but it does
raise a question about what the
government actually means when it
declares a business essential thus
allowing it to stay open or in essential
thus forcing it to close and possibly
driving it irretrievably irretrievably
into ruin now I'm not arguing that the
stores that I mentioned best buy Dunkin
Donuts and stores like it or for that
matter the liquor stores that are open
or any of the other businesses that are
benevolent overlords have allowed to
stay but I'm not arguing that they
should be closed that's not my point I'm
glad they're open I'm happy about that
my point is that every other business
should be open to because the
government's system of designate
designating something essential or in
essential is arbitrary unjust absurd and
subjective and I don't think it's a
coincidence that the wealthy and
politically connected big corporations
are so often allowed to stay open while
it's the small businesses that don't
have a lot of money and don't have
connections and don't have power that
are are being are being destroyed being
wiped out you know I don't think that's
a coincidence so I think we've accepted
this essential versus non-essential
designation without without much
question we should have questioned it a
lot more and ask the
very basically what what do you mean by
that if the term essential has any
objective meaning when applied to a
business it would have to be as far as I
could tell that an essential business is
one that people depend on for survival
right now I and the government must be
taking a pretty broad view of that
because no one's gonna die without
Dunkin Donuts or Best Buy or Dairy Queen
or Taco Bell but you know the fast food
places they sell food and best buy sell
stuff that you might need for work so in
it from a very understanding us in a
very broad way they sell things that you
might need you might depend on right
okay but then every other business fits
that bill as well that's the point every
business has people depending on it even
if a business is expendable as far as
the customers are concerned and even
that might not be the case I mean to
whatever extent customers depend on Best
Buy I bet there are people who depend on
you know even like barber shops just as
much I would put those as far as the the
the products and services they provide I
would put those about on the same level
in terms of how essential they are but
taking a broader view of it what
whatever the customer the customers look
at it the fact is that any business is
going to have people depending on it
certainly the employees and the people
that run the business depend on it and
that is why every business is in a very
real and urgent sense essential to
somebody so it's obviously ludicrous to
suggest that Walmart and Target are
essential to me because that's what
they're saying right when they when the
government says this this business is
open because it's essential what they're
really saying is it's essential to you
as a member of the community Target
Walmart are essential to you whether or
not that's the case your job and your
income are more essential to you it
doesn't make a
sense to say that Walmart is essential
to you but your own job is not essential
to you because the essentialness of a
product is kind of irrelevant if you
don't have the money to buy it which
means that your income will always be
more fundamentally essential than
anything you might find at a store so as
we speak there are thousands of people
across the country waiting in line for
hours at food banks because they can't
afford the so-called essential services
that these businesses are providing the
their source of income has been declared
less essential than the items they would
use their income to purchase that
doesn't make any sense the insanity of
that kind of system I think should be
readily apparent to everybody if a
product or service is essential then the
means by which I purchase that product
or service must also be essential if you
remove the latter then you've also
removed the former you if you deprive me
of the latter you deprive me of the
former because again the word essential
doesn't mean anything if it doesn't if
we're not talking about essential to
people and nobody can deny that one of
the most essential things to a person is
his job
so all businesses are essential which
means that it's time to open up them up
again and I'm glad that some states are
starting to do that we're going to go to
we have a number of important new stores
when you go to in just a second but
speaking of important before we do that
you know even during this time when
people are locked at home your beard
hygiene and the your facial hair
appearance are still very important you
can let everything else go to hell but
at least have as a man or a woman if you
have a beard you know I don't I don't
judge you got to have enough
self-respect to keep the beard in
tip-top shape if you're sitting at home
giving the Quarantine beard a shot you
you probably already know that it's it's
not as easy a look it's not as easy as
it looks to have it I mean this beard
that I have here and I've got it trimmed
a little bit short right now but there's
a lot of work that goes into this to
look this good with the beard it's not
that
okay beards can try out and get itchy
they can look bad sometimes as heretical
as it may seem to say beard supply helps
keep your beard healthy itch free soft
smelling grades and more than ten
thousand beards agree beard supply
products are the best out there and ten
thousand beards can't be wrong one beard
can't be wrong each beard supply beard
oil is hand crafted from 100% natural
ingredients with no synthetics no
mass-market essentials no sulfates no
paraphernalia is it sounds like
something you'd find in the ocean I
don't know this stuff is basically just
squeeze right out of Earth directly onto
your beard plus they come in tons of
great smells like the woods winter the
year 1975 great smell historically great
smelling year I think I also thought
1993 was a great smelling we year join
thousands of other bearded guys who are
enjoying softer better smelling less
itchy beards for a short time beard
Supply is offering Matt Walsh o
listeners 25% off just got a beard
supply calm and use the promo code Walsh
again that's beard supply calm promo
code Walsh so this is going predictably
viral so we go to our first story here
it's a footage of a mom at a playground
in Idaho arrested for being on the
playground with our kids okay this is
not officer you don't want to do that
[Music]
oh now I'm recording someone else else
okay can you call
hurt her kids are here that again is in
Idaho where there have been less than
2000 confirmed or probable cases as the
Idaho gov website puts it at about fifty
deaths yet they don't want you to go on
the playground now the defense I've seen
of this of the cop anyway the defense
that some people have offered is that
he's doing his job he didn't make the
rule he tried to be nice the woman was
being difficult
all of that is true but what happens
let's say if all or most of the cops in
the department just said to stand up and
say we're not going to enforce these
kinds of rules okay we're not gonna go
and put a mother in handcuffs for having
her kid on a swing what if the cops say
that are they gonna fire all the cops in
the town I think what we need is is
police officers to step up here do the
brave thing in these cases and simply
refuse to enforce policies like this
because as we know following orders is
not always a sufficient excuse number
two here's a fascinating case speaking
of kids and on playgrounds and elsewhere
this is interesting from the Guardian
reading now from the Guardian says a
nine-year-old boy who contracted Cova
nineteen in eastern France did not pass
the virus on despite coming into contact
with more than a hundred and seventy
people according to research that
suggests children may not be major
spreaders of the virus the boy was among
a cluster of cases linked to Steve Walsh
the businessman who became the first
person in Britain to test positive for
coronavirus after attending a sales
conference in Singapore in January Walsh
unknown relations by the way unwittingly
as far as I know but who knows passed
the infection on when he joined 10
British adults and a family of five at a
chalet and the ski resort in a ski
resorts region it goes off there but
anyway the point is just summarizing we
don't need all the details this was a
young child showed moderate you know my
symptoms okay it wasn't very sick came
in contact with a hundred 70 people
didn't pass it on to anybody apparently
now this is just one case but it is very
interesting and if it holds true then
this would mean that we already know
that kids are not personally affected by
this very very much or very often and if
they also are not likely to spread the
virus then you have to start to wonder
why the school still closed why the
playgrounds closed right number three I
hope you're ready to be severely creeped
out because here's a poll that was
posted by Morning Joe of Morning Joe and
MSNBC that posted a poll the poll
question should non-essential workers be
allowed to move freely outside results
seventy-five percent of the respondents
of the polls say no they should not how
much of a boot licking submissive do you
have to be to say no to that question
should they be allowed to move freely
outside if they're non-essential what an
absolutely creepy question everything
about that it's not even just should not
essential workers be allowed to go to
work to saying no to that in my view is
bad enough
another thing should they be able to
move freely outside no for now let's go
to something a little bit more
inspirational and positive Mayor Bill de
Blasio of New York set up a tip line a
phone number where people could call or
text to report any violations of social
distancing that they observe in their
communities a snitch line basically for
god-forsaken tattletales that's not the
inspirational part the inspirational
part is that people really stepped up to
the plate did the right thing and
flooded the tip line with obscene
pictures and prank calls beautiful I
mean god bless america
that this this is the America that I
know and love this is not not all the
people snitching on their if their
neighbors but this is what America is
all about so reading for The Daily wire
says the New York Post reports that New
Yorkers and other assorted
de Blasio critics flooded his new tip
line with crank complaints including
photos of genitalia
and people flipping the bird the bird
photos of extended middle fingers the
mayor dropping the Staten Island
groundhog and news coverage of him going
to the gym have all been texted to a
special tip line that the Blasio
announced Saturday
according to screenshots posted to
Twitter the outlet adds that it is not
immediately clear whether the offender's
the offending textures all live in New
York some of the mayor's detractors took
particular delight in reporting the
Blasio himself to the tip line
especially given that the New York mayor
dragged his feet in instituting
shelter-in-place orders and so on and he
was like they say he was going to the
gym he's driving whatever it is 12 miles
to go to walk in a park so it looks like
he was the man he was the main one
reported to his own tip line beautiful
stuff now we go from that very tragic
again reading now from CNN it says the
world is facing multiple famines of
biblical proportions quote unquote in
just a matter of months the UN has said
warning that the corona virus pandemic
will push an additional 130 million
people to the brink of starvation
famines could take hold in about three
dozen countries in a worst-case scenario
the executive director of the World Food
Program said ten of those countries
already have more than a million people
on the verge of starvation
he cited conflict economic recession a
decline in aid and a collapse in oil
prices as factors likely to lead to vast
food shortages and urge swift action to
avert the disaster so 100 million people
on the brink of starvation because of
this and by the way remember the
collapse in oil prices
Alexander Kaiser Cortes said she loves
to say she absolutely loves it she loves
it the oil prices are collapsing and yet
millions of people will be on the brink
of starvation because of it so she loves
that but beyond that I mean this is a
large part of the reason here is because
of the shutdowns not just in America but
across the world the disruption in the
in the supply chain and that's gonna
spur on potentially mass starvation
like we were talking about before it is
by no means a foregone conclusion that
the shutdown's
have actually saved lives it's there's
there's a seems like a pretty
significant likelihood that it will lead
to many more deaths this is one aspect
we haven't talked about we talked about
suicide rates going up drug abuse going
up you know domestic violence things
like that
and just even people in this country who
are not able you know the homelessness
and and and all of these all of these
factors on the rise and that puts lines
at risk and then when you look when you
step back and you look at it on a global
scale and you think about the
potentially tens of millions hundreds of
millions of people who could be on the
brink of starvation it's looking like
the shutdown's could be a humanitarian
disaster unlike anything we've seen the
recent times six finally a bonus story
here that I wanted to mention airlines
are trying to figure out how to
reconfigure their seating arrangements
in a post corona world and here's what
one manufacturer came up with it this is
a potential model that could be used by
Airlines so take a look at the picture
you see there you've got I mean my God
in heaven I I would you get the middle
seat middle seat was already bad enough
and now it already dehumanizing and
claustrophobic enough now they want to
imprison the middle seat in a plastic
case so that there's definitely no space
for your elbows or anything and then
even worse than that I mean that's bad
enough with it now they want to flip the
middle seat around so that you're
directly facing the people in the aisle
in the aisle and window seat behind you
and then what happens if you have to
cough now you're coughing towards other
people this is their solution now I
would say that at least this works out
if you're on an aisle or a window seat
because then the person next to you is
encased in glass so that would avoid you
think okay that's going to avoid
unwanted conversation which is great but
the problem is that the
seat in front of you now you've got
their dumb face looking at you for the
entire flight so this is gonna mean that
the most coveted seat on the entire
plane will be the the window seat at the
very front of the plane because now
you've got the privacy because you got
the glass case on one side you've got
the window on the other no one's talking
to you no one can and then there's
nobody in front of you facing you so
that's gonna be very covered seat
there's gonna be violence riots over
that seat plus there's gonna be an
upcharge of course it's gonna be $700 up
charge just to sit in that one in that
one good seat left on the plane of
course if the airlines really cared
about reducing transmission of diseases
and everything rather than finding ways
to keep people crammed together what
they might consider doing is like
removing the middle seat even in some
cases to give people more space and now
we could be socially distance on the
plane they don't want to do that because
that means they're gonna sacrifice money
all right let's go to our daily
cancellation I'm gonna be canceling the
brand Burt's Bees which I think makes
lip balm and some other stuff actually
this this specifically is the Burt's
Bees baby brand and they make I don't
know lip balm for babies I'm not sure
but anyway Burt's Bees baby posted
something on Instagram now especially on
Instagram brands will often attempt to
be inspiring you know relatable
encouraging and these attempts as the
kids would say are cringe almost always
now here's the thing brands if you are a
brand just be a brand sell your product
don't try to inspire me I'm not going to
a brand the first for inspiration I'm
not I'm not looking at an advertisement
to be inspired
just just sell what you came here to
sell and be on your way all right just
get to it sell your product and be done
with it
but the reason Burt's Bees baby is
getting canceled in particular is
because they win when it when it comes
to trying to inspire people they went
way way way way over the top in this
desperate attempt to be encouraging and
inspirational
I want you to look at this post here's
the picture this is on Instagram their
Instagram page this is the picture then
the caption from the brand this is what
it says this is not what you had planned
this is not what you'd envisioned there
are no visits from friends no loving
doula bringing you soup no mommy and me
yoga classes no coffee dates no stroller
walks through the park there is empty
space where you had planned comfort and
company there are long days with no one
but your little one to talk to and this
big transition to navigate all alone I
know it's lonely mama I know though mama
it's that creepy to have a brand talking
to you this way I know it's lonely mama
I know the walls of your house feel
tight and the days feel so long and you
crave a warm hand on your knee and the
soft embrace of a friend you wish for
someone by your side to marvel at this
beautiful baby of yours and to wrap an
arm around you with the feelings when
the feelings get too big and scary I
remind you this is a brand that makes
lip balm okay we were never we were
never meant to do this alone motherhood
has never been a solitary sport and yet
here we are in this odd chapter of
isolation and distance with no choice
but to do it by ourselves but mama know
this we are alone together you are
surrounded by all the other mothers who
are navigating this tender time in
isolation you are held by all of us who
have walked the path before you and who
know how much you must be hurting right
now you are wrapped in the warm embrace
of mama earth as she too settles into
this time of slowness and healing this
too shall pass
and when it does hugs and coffee dates
and visits from friends will taste so
much sweeter soft kisses on your cheek
and arms around your waist and gentle
laughter and your eel ear will be the
joyful medicine after this trying time
until then hunker down mama find the
coziest warmest spot on the couch sink
into the pile of unfolded laundry and
spend this spring with that sweet babe
warm on your chest jeez
Burt's Bees take it down a notch
take it down several notches just calm
down a little
you sell lip balm okay this is what
we're talking about here take it easy by
the way um crave a warm hand on your
knee is that now look I'm not a woman as
far as I know but who knows I mean
anybody could be these days so but maybe
I'm a little bit ignorant so the
ignorant end to doubt that that I guess
you tell me ladies do do you crave a
warm hand on your knee is that a thing
that I mean is any woman sitting around
craving a warm hand on the knee I mean
any kind of hand at all would be bad
enough but a warm hand we know you want
a warm sweaty clammy hand creepily
caressing your leg who did Joe Biden
write this thing now in fairness to
Burt's Bees I looked at the comments on
this Instagram post and there were I
have to admit a lot of women commenting
with stuff like wow I needed this today
thank you or I'm in tears thank you so
much but I refuse to believe that those
people are real I think that they're
BOTS or they're I bring them there they
work for Burt's Bees I refuse to believe
who goes to Burt's Bees Instagram
account looking for solace and comfort I
really needed to feel human connection
so I went to a to a brand's social media
page to find it I guess that's a sign
that you really are lonely maybe you
could use a warm hand on the knee who
knows
so Burt's Bees is canceled and so is
anybody else who got inspired by what I
just read there you're all cancelled
okay
let's go to emails but before we do that
you know during this quarantine we've
been trying to find ways to little ways
to keep people entertained and and help
people out a little bit well here's
here's a great deal when you become a
daily wire insider plus our all-access
member right now you will get not one
but two of the highly coveted leftist
ears tumblers and this is a tumbler that
you know there are a lot of tumblers out
there on the
but none of them can do what this
tumbler does which is it holds liquid
okay
and now you can hold one liquid and
another liquid because you've got two of
these things daily water members get
many amazing benefits along with the
Magnificent leftist cirrus tumblers you
also get an ad-free website experience
access to our two-hour live broadcast
show library the full three hours of ben
shapiro show every day access to the
mailbag and now exclusive election
insight op-eds from ben shapiro daily
wire members also get to ask us
questions during the backstage
and you also get to participate in the
all-access live shows as well so you
just get a ton of benefits here along
with as I said the two left is tears
tumblers not just one but two so become
a daily wire insider plus or all-access
member and you also get 10% off if you
use coupon code Welsh speaking of the
backstage events tune in today seven
o'clock Eastern Time there will be a
backstage live show which are always a
lot of fun I'll be stopping by virtually
for that as well and so tune in for that
now let's go to emails and you can also
email if you become a daily where I
remember you can email using the mailbag
this is from Mike says can a guy cry
during a movie while while you are
supreme and ultimate emperor for example
I couldn't help but shed a tear during
the movie crash specifically when the
little girl was shot and the dad cried
in pain could help but think that what
if that happened to one of my children
that's sign from Mike okay well Mike
we've talked about this and it is
acceptable for a man to cried during a
movie but that movie has to be I
mentioned Rudy ok Rudy's a an example
you could cry during that movie there
might be a few other examples
some people say Old Yeller no I think
crying over an animal as a man is not
acceptable when my pets die I don't cry
I harvest them for meat and fur like a
real man ok that's how a man should
respond to that but there are movies is
the point where you view cry is crash
one of them absolutely not you in fact
you could not have chosen a least a less
manly movie to cry over this is this is
probably the worst movie that you could
possibly cry over I can't think of a
worse I mean
maybe a worse one would be if you cried
over like the devil's Devil Wears Prada
because male Meryl Streep is being so
rude to her employees and you cried over
that that might be a little bit worse
but only a little bit this is pretty bad
crash come on this is a this is a
permanent revocation of the man card
you're never getting it back you might
as well transition at this point because
the man cards never come back to you
sorry from Brian says despite often
agreeing with you have to say I disagree
with your take that our elected
officials are implementing these extreme
lockdown measures simply out of greed I
believe it is out of a fear of appearing
to not take the corona virus seriously
enough I live in Pennsylvania so let's
use that as an example once all is said
and done the governor of PA is going to
be judged by the public and the media by
the statistics in the state number of
deaths death rate hospitalizations etc
therefore whether or not these lockdown
measures work he's implementing them so
that he can point to all of these
extreme policies and at least say hey
look we tried our best sure some
politicians may be power-hungry but it
is more out of a risk aversion than
anything else yeah bright I don't
disagree it's not an either/or here
anytime you've got disastrous policies
policies from the government there are
going to be multiple things going into
it and the various bureaucrats and
politicians involved in bringing that
plan and that policy to fruition are
going to be motivated by different
things so I don't think it's an
either/or I do believe there's a huge
element of as you're talking about here
Acy a cover-your-ass move here by the
politicians who they see everybody else
locking down and so they figure I got to
do it too and they also think ok let me
do this and then I won't be liable for
the deaths and then also you can't blame
me for destroying the economy because
everybody else is doing it too and so
there's this security they find in
numbers basically so that's part of it
but it's also very clear that a lot of
these bureaucrats and politicians are
having a power or power-drunk
are high on their own power are enjoying
all the power they've been given and and
want to exert that and express it for
its own sake so I think that's also
happening let's go to Julia also my
daughter's name by the way
hi I'm at this isn't really a why you're
wrong thing because I'm only partially
sure that you are wrong but in your
diatribe defending homeschooling you
seem to avoid the best argument against
it and for formal schooling and that is
socialization what would you say to the
argument that parents should send their
kids to school to be socialized okay
yeah we talked about homeschooling a few
days ago in the show because Harvard had
published Harvard magazine had published
an article advocating banning
homeschooling they're also doing a
summit on the dangers of homeschooling
where they're gonna talk about
regulations that should be put on
homeschooling to protect kids from the
horrible dangers of homeschooling you
bring up the socialization argument well
first of all not to get into semantics
here but yeah I don't agree with your
dichotomy between formal schooling or or
homeschooling homeschooling is a form of
formal schooling it's it is formal now
there is something called unschooling
which I'm not an expert on it so I can't
speak very intelligently about it but
from what I understand of the
unschooling strategy that is essentially
in formal schooling where there's no
formal structure but that's not what
home schoolers do if somebody's an
unschoolers an their unschooling and
that's what they'll say so home
schooling is formal that's the first
thing in terms of being socialized what
I always say about that is if the public
school system is the best way to
socialize your kid then I say the proof
should be in the pudding
so show me the pudding but let's take a
look we've got multiple generations of
kids who many of them now grown adults
who have multiple generations of people
who were largely shaped and formed by
the public school system they were
public schooled right or at least they
were pride they were in the private
school they were in the education system
in some capacity so let's just look
around at society and you tell me does
it
appear that people are very well
socialized I would say no so we don't
need to theorize about whether or not
the public school environment is is a
good way to socialize kids we don't need
to theorize about it I could say we have
enough data at this point that you can
look around and see clearly it's not
working and then when you look in the
schools and you see the bullying problem
a I mean it's it's the media that the
people who are advocates in the public
school system they're the ones who are
constantly telling us about the bullying
epidemic and and so on so according to
them there's a bullying epidemic there's
peer pressure there's and we know that
things like suicide the suicide rate
among kids is way higher now than it's
been in the past
and we you know and and so I just I
don't see the evidence that kids are
becoming well-adjusted quote socialized
people through the public school system
I don't see the evidence for it and I
don't see the evidence that home
schooling is turning kids into weirdo
rec losses I know that that's the
stereotype but in my experience that is
simply not the case
so there's just there's no evidence for
this and when you get beyond that it's I
think it's pretty clear that the public
school system is not a great way to
socialize kids and here's why because
when we talk about socializing our kids
what do we mean I guess we couldn't
maybe we need to define our terms a
little bit we couldn't mean different
things by it but when I think about
socializing a kid what I mean by that is
helping them to become mature
well-adjusted people who can function in
society that's what I mean well what's
the best way to do that I mean or it may
be a better way of putting it who is
best equipped to socialize a kid to get
them to a point where they are mature
and well-adjusted and ready to be
functioning members of society
my answer is adults adults should be the
one the ones socializing kids teaching
them
to become well-adjusted people problem
though in the public school system is
you're throwing kids into a school
there's thirty kids in a class you know
they're the kids way outnumber the the
adults and so who is doing the
socializing in the public school
environment the answer is other kids so
the kids are being socialized by other
kids by that sort of peer culture
they're being oriented to the world by
their peers and the thing is they're
looking at their at their friends for
social cues and for cues on how they're
supposed to act and what kind of person
they're supposed to be while their
friends are looking back at them so
they're all they're just running in
circles and nobody has a it's it's a
classic blind leading the blind scenario
in home school even if you have a big
family which a lot of home schoolers do
the fact is you know the ratio of kid to
adult is a much lower and not on top of
that it's also you know it's a parent
rather than being some stranger a
teacher who has the kids for forty five
minutes for a period and then they go
for and you know they have another
teacher so I think there's a much better
chance in homeschooling of a child being
socialized and oriented to the world
into society by an adult taking cues
from adults and so it's and I know this
is anecdotal okay I don't have any
studies in front of me although I'm sure
I could probably dig some up but in my
experience it seems like homeschooled
kids are way more mature way more mature
than public school kids are and this is
and I've got a lot of experience you
know I went to public school myself I've
met I know plenty of public school
families but I've also been in the home
school environment for a long time even
before I homeschool my own kids I've
been to tons of homeschool conferences
and conventions and everything speaking
at them or attending them myself
and so you know a pretty pretty big
sample size my experience is homeschool
kids are way more mature even things
like I've noticed things that are subtle
or maybe not so subtle but things like
home school kids it seems to me much
more likely to shake your hand and look
you in the eye
or just in general look you in the eye
when you speak to them whereas other
kids often when you talk to them they've
got they're looking down like this they
don't want to look at you so things like
that
public homeschool kids tend to be better
at it and I think my anecdote my
anecdotal evidence probably holds true
because of this reason that I'm giving
that it is you think about the
environment that they're in they're
learning from their parents they're
being oriented to the world by the
parents they're taking social cues from
the parents they're learning from adults
rather than you throw them into this sea
of other kids and they're just caught up
in all that chaos and trying to figure
out you know what kind of person to be
based on on their peers and they also
become because they're in this peer
culture they become a to be accepted by
their peers and they're gonna do
whatever they can to be accepted because
to be in public school environment you
know if you're a young kid in public
school you know you're gonna be in this
environment for 12 years starting in
kindergarten kindergarten longer than
that for some kids but you know you're
gonna be in this environment for a long
time and so if you're ostracized if
you're not accepted then that's gonna be
very hard to deal with for your through
your entire formative the formative
years of your childhood and so kids
become desperate to become accepted and
when they're not accepted that's why we
have the suicide epidemic and it's not
as simple as a kid is bullied and they
feel bad about themselves and they go
home and kill themselves it's not that
simple at all what it is is kids are
their entire world becomes their peers
and when they are not accepted when
they're rejected then it feels to them
like they're being rejected by the
entire world and they don't know how to
handle that they don't know how to cope
with it and sometimes they resort to
horrific things and even if it's not
suicide drug abuse and other things you
know as in that desperation to be
accepted so that's what the
socialization process involves in public
school and I just don't see it as
superior at all the homeless go home
school in fact it is this for me the
number one argument for home school you
ask me what's the what
but if I could give you one reason why
you should homeschool your kids it will
be exactly this socialization is the
reason that I homeschool more than
anything else all right
but thanks for that question a very
interesting topic and we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]